lopez had a knocked away good play by
collins
back and goes to herder young
fake behind the back and then the drive
is able to score
what a spectacular play by trae young
[Music]
how about the fake here by trey just
kind of
throws clowns in a little bit and then
another
pop 79-75 atlanta
jump into the paint
in this game it's been free-flowing look
at this move
take your time a little shuffle and then
let's see
okay
this is when you can run the the highest
grid in the rolls before the defense is
set
[Music]
here removed by young he hits it a foul
what a play by trae young off the
hesitation
all evening has not got it and if you're
coach
bus do you green light this
well if he wasn't a household name
before these playoffs he is now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
once again three-point lead
for the bucks they'll be in possession
in their front court
[Music]
gets to middleton he has a three-point
shot it is
to the crowd and the atlanta hawks have
come up with an upset
as they defeat the milwaukee bucks here
in milwaukee
in game number one of this best of seven
trae young leading the way 48 points
11 assists 17 for 34
from the field well they got the look
they wanted from the player
that they wanted chris middleton online
just not long enough and the atlanta
hawks
still again game one they did it versus
the knicks they did it in philly
and here actually it's the first time in
there
in franchise history let's go to
stephanie thanks marv trey here we are
again
you all had another run at the end of a
game on the road
how are you doing it
what we've been doing we just keep
fighting and uh it's been fun playing
with this group
and we just keep fighting to the end no
matter what the score is
uh that's what we're going to do we're
going to keep fighting what are the keys
for you all defensively
when you have play another team with all
of those weapons
and you have to get a stop yeah we got
weapons too uh
i believe in this this team too i mean
they got they got some good pieces over
there
uh got a really a lot of really talented
people um but we do too
and like i said i believe in this team
and we knew we could get a stop
if we just we just buckled down and got
it we've talked a lot about how you all
believe in each other
tonight was an example of that it wasn't
the best start
but it seemed like your confidence never
wavered tell us about this team
yeah i mean we our confidence never goes
away uh we put too much work in we've
gotten
too far uh we came too far to get here
and to stop believing in each other and
uh
that's what we're gonna keep doing we're
gonna keep fighting until until it's
over with
and uh like i said i believe in this
group thanks for stopping
congratulations nice appreciate you
so a new playoff career high for
portray young's high hall season two
career highs 50 points
48 tonight 116
113 the final atlanta over milwaukee
young with 12 points
in the quarter